hi I'm Hannah Kendra and I'm Blake
Lively's and this is the wired
autocomplete it's her first time on
camera oh she's gonna be okay ready is
Anna Kendrick
scrappy Dappy yeah
scrappy af I'll tear your face off is
Anna Kendrick Squirrel Girl okay what
does that one person asked me if I want
it if I would ever be a superhero and my
brother had sent me the Squirrel Girl
comics and I said oh yeah I'd like to be
Squirrel Girl because I assumed that
would be one of those answers that just
like goes away instead of saying
something that becomes clickbait boy was
I wrong I know that was actually a thing
yeah then it was like Anna Kendrick
first Squirrel Girl and I was like oh I
didn't know I appreciate the effort but
I didn't need you guys to start a whole
campaign is Anna Kendrick Olivia
oh my god I've tricked people into
thinking I have a good personality no
I'm not Canadian
I'm super made but you would be
surprised how many people think that
Maine is a part of Canada read a book is
Anna Kendrick in go Smith no but there's
a girl in the band echosmith who does
look a lot like me which is why I know
what the band echosmith
is shout out to you echo Smith is Anna
Kendrick related to catch or follow no
way that anybody thinks that there's no
way I don't know um
I feel like I'm on dangerous territory
answering this no we're not related but
also what yeah it's his first name yeah
I can't that's the shot this is sugar so
so what's the answer
Ben no I wish I win would that be cool
how does Blake Lively work out how do
you work out my gosh is this so
interesting I'm so glad people are
interested in my career I work out with
Don Saladino trainer to the stars
how does Blake Lively dance
they think there's gonna be a video
cause if they thought that was a video
surely they would Google like fleek
lately dancing how does she dance like
very question about how you dance
tell us in words maybe maybe it's
because like I'm I'm sad or my husband
said like I use a lot of elbows in life
so maybe like they think it's just like
a very elbow we dance and if they
thought that they would be correct
oh how to Blake Lively delete her
Instagram so on Instagram they have it's
not really deleting your Instagram
because you just hide your post and then
you can get them back if you want but
only pop stars do it and you know I
meant you're in the Illuminati
campaigning to become a pop star yeah so
um I thought it would bring me one step
closer okay how's that working no not
very well good
how did Blake Lively get her name
my grandmother's brother was named Blake
oh but he was murdered so thanks for
asking Google
she's so dark it does Anna Kendrick
actually sing let's just do it right now
should I show um boss
actually um bleak Miley's song it's
actually yeah I have a note thing well
the pitch pipe yeah no but I always want
to be really waka okay go ahead
do you actually sing yeah beautifully
she really does does Anna Kendrick use
autotune how dare you how very dare no
that is rude no I don't have I had to do
more than one take yes have I used
auto-tune yes does Anna Kendrick have
siblings I do I have an older brother
named Mike who is responsible for all
the cynical awful parts of my
personality cuz he beat me up almost
daily and he's responsible for the
squirrel girl that's true okay roll girl
rumor girls class back um is Blake
Lively
[Laughter]
my lack of trying everyone I've ever met
ever it's offensive I like people that I
haven't heard from and so long yeah it's
like somehow they have a route to my
even company appreciate it invite makes
it seem lovely it's an invite no Lincoln
is just fine it's a parasite herpes yeah
is Blake Lively's ooh hair naturally
curly that's a nice question it is not
it's wavy it's naturally wavy is Blake
Lively oh this is a long one Wow on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame
oh yeah I recently got a star on the
Walk of Fame
whoo in El Maria Spain a little town no
ceremony it was like it was in the
cafeteria the ceremony on a lunch break
do they call the real Hollywood okay
there's like no actual walk but they did
shoot Indiana Jones The Last Crusade
there and the Lords of Arabia so I'm
sort of like thinking of myself in that
yeah like Peter O'Toole Harrison Ford
way yeah for sure
what Anna Kendrick what Anna Kendrick
what Anna Kendrick character are you
what oh is that like a quiz mmm that's
cool
I'm Stephanie from a simple favor and
there September 14th
what is Anna Kendrick's number nice try
boys and girls I see you know what is
Anna Kendrick's Vietnam what is my like
what is my personal Vietnam I haven't
had one that's so harrowing what does
Anna Kendrick play it oh I hate that I
hate when people freeze it like did you
plan w what movie did you play in yeah
some time to answer that what is Blake
Lively's zodiac sign Virgo what's that
what's that is super attention to detail
and and very like fastidious I'd tell
that about Leo but the Leo thing is like
sort of this yes same thing what is it
like what are we doing now really that's
a really weird thing to go like oh noes
but I feel like Siri would be like oh by
the way here's what she's doing right
now cuz she listens to everything that's
been she's standing yeah what is a Blake
Lively ring well she's got a couple
today clearly not a nuvaring oh she's
got children